I guess let's just get started with the
panel. I'd like uh all the panelists to
introduce themselves, say what they
happen to be, what organization they um
are with and how their work relates to
uh data analytics or network science.
So, uh what Allison, you've got the mic.
Go for it.
>> Apparently, I have the mic, so I'm up. I
am Allison Coette. I am a developer
relations advocate at Neo4j and my
specialty is in graph data science.
>> Hi, I'm Arit. Uh I'm a senior lecturer
for strategy and complexity university
London and most of my work is on cities
and the future of cities and cities are
networks by definition. So that's kind
of what got me through the door.
>> Yeah, I'm Andre. I'm the CTO at
agodicc.ai. Uh, and our work is
essentially building world models for
organizations that entails essentially
creating like a magic twin of an
organization to understand what are the
best actions that they can take to
improve certain outcomes. And we do view
uh an organization as essentially like a
very big network uh with an underlying
graph as the as a primary data model.
Uh I'm
Wayong or just call me way. Um my
previous life I was a physicist and then
I start two companies. One called
kinetic arts uh focus on bringing
science, technology, data into dance
performances. We host weekly labs where
people come together, experiment on
things. Uh the idea is if you have
something working it's probably not does
not belong here. If it's not working yes
let's get let's play with it. Uh the
other side is founded kavis is focus on
uh that that's the other way around.
Let's bring art and uh how human
perceive the information into data
visualization and solving um some
practical problems and uh found out the
graph is really interesting and very
very practical very helpful. So that's
how we started using graph and getting
deep into the graph. Today we offer a
lot of graph solutions but a lot of this
focus on visual uh visualizations and
visual transformation of the graph data.
Thank you.
So I'm going to ask a question out of
order here. Uh that uh I've noticed this
and actually while I know your
background also has a lot of physics in
it, but I've noticed in both network
science and in the graph uh analytics or
more advanced graph space, there's a lot
of people with physics backgrounds.
What gives? Why is that? I mean, I love
both spaces,
>> but but it just seems like an unusual,
you know, cross uh cross pattern. What
do you what do you guys think? You
>> want to go ahead?
>> Yeah.
>> So, yeah. So, in physics, um I was
working on things that were in the
adjacency of statistical physics applied
to both condensed matter, which is
basically understanding like okay, if I
put a lot of a lot of particles in this
box, what's going to happen to them? And
also to high energy physics, for
instance, what happens when a black for
a black hole is formed? uh so one thing
that generally happens in physics is
that uh look there is one way of
understanding a system which is let's
say like an ensemble right so I have all
the air in the room I don't need to care
about what each particle is doing I
don't need to care about the network
because I know that it all sort of
averages out so the chances that all the
gas in the room are going to go to the
corner and suffocate me to death in here
are essentially zero uh but not zero. Uh
which is what happens when systems they
get complex, right? Which is why the the
study of complexity is so interesting
because if the dynamics they're
complicated, then you can no longer go
on this assumption that you can just
average out everything, right? There's
no such thing as the average person in
the room or the average commute in a
system. So you actually need to go deep
into the system to understand okay what
are the intricacies of all of the
different couplings between the
different elements in there in order to
actually simulate and study what are the
non-trivial
uh dynamics that will arrive from there
right so and often times you actually
need to think in terms of networks you
need to think in terms of graphs because
it is the best way to model uh the the
the agency of each one of the the
elements of of the system.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm kind of curious or um in the city
space in the network science and city
space do you also find a lot of
crossover from physics or is this more
kind of in the computer science network
science space that we see this?
>> No, it is absolutely I mean by essence
it is interdisciplinary.
Um so a city is a physical space to
begin with right? So the movement within
that space is really really important.
uh but then how do you pull together
physical elements and psychological and
cultural and technological and economic
and political and for me this is the
magic of it. So really starting with the
observation of of almost like problem
solving. So this is a state of the
system. So we look at it at the system
level but we want to change it. We want
to move the air from one place to
another. So how do you start doing that
and how do you make sense of the system
is always what is driving me in that
sense and and you need that input from
everyone which is you know why it's
fascinating.
>> I I love that we're we're like getting
super geeky really fast. Um we do you
have some more uh geek for us?
>> Yeah just couple points my own
experience.
Um,
one physics training trains you to model
everything. It's like you you have this
hammer a magic hammer
of hammering things to model things.
You're trying to simplify things like
the simplest way you can describe
something usually it's the right way.
That's what people wants to believe. So
we have this bad habit or good habit of
trying to model everything. That's
number one. Number two, I happen to be
in the same field, condensed matter
field, work on the quantum dots. And a
lesson I learned is, you know, when you
grow up, you learn everything,
everything seems to be so clear. So um
solid foundation like it's beautiful
palace and then you go to condensed
matter you realize it's dirty it's
madness it's nothing is solid everything
is like fuzzy and you're trying to
figure out something that you can
actually hold on to and um that
experience uh really echoes when I work
with the data with the with the graph
data it's like there's part that you
think it's it's clear it's um um it's
solid but then when you get into it get
deeper into it you realize a lot of
things is really not as clear as it is.
So that's just my experience thing.
>> So if we um maybe maybe uh Allison this
might be a question that that you might
want to jump in. How should we think
about the difference between network
science uh graph theory and graph
technology?
It's a I I think the key for me
obviously I come from the graph
technology side. Uh I think the more we
spend time together the better. Honestly
I I think sometimes the way it's viewed
is that the graph technology side is
over overly simplified. And in some ways
that's true. If we look at what's
possible in exploring a graph like
you're mentioning with cities and like
true complex systems approaches um I
think there's a lot more that can be
done in our commercial space to bring
that thinking to the enterprise right
obviously this is what you folks are
doing right now um and I definitely
think there's a call for that and you
know for me
you know let's be honest most of the
graph algorithms that people are running
right now are pretty simple and pretty
straightforward. And I don't think that
it's because there's a I I think it's
just a matter of evolution and a matter
of timing because we're starting to move
from being data driven to being system
driven and it's just taking folks a
little bit of time to really get there.
So, so sorry. Uh, Orura, uh, as a
network and a practicing network
scientist, how do you view the
difference in and what do you think
about what Allison had to say?
>> I think it really is and and going back
to what we said as well, the magic is in
the messiness. Um, and the real
challenge is how do you capture that
messiness?
And from my experience, it's it's always
been really really difficult. and and
and with you know a lot of failure. Um
and it drives a lot of work actually
towards the more abstract and conceptual
and qualitative side of things. And I
think that trying to figure out how you
can actually capture the messiness
without reducing it
>> is is the real challenge. And this is
why I'm here to learn how you can
actually do that.
>> Okay. that I like that the the magic is
in the messiness. Maybe that's a a
wonderful that is a great t-shirt, too.
But as uh computer scientists or and and
some of us um you know trying to make a
living in the technology space um we
tend to hate messiness like it messes
with our models. It messes with our
predictions. It but it is where the
magic is. So how you know how how do you
you know try to deal with that? I'm
going to throw that at you. Yeah,
actually that was a perfect question
because echo exactly what I had what I
had in mind which is like okay uh
because I'm a physicist and because you
open that can of worms I have to go back
in there right which is the following
look if I'm modeling uh an airplane uh
or even something simple as let's say
the the like the sound waves on that
table I don't need to understand like
the deep fundamental truth about the
universe and everything. I just need to
know like basic Newtonian physics,
right? So all that messiness gets
encapsulated into a certain degrees of
freedom that actively represent the
system for all intents and purposes
almost perfectly. Right? So uh that uh
that element of course graining allows
us to actually capture what is
essential. So for me it's always about
okay what is essential about that system
that needs to be modeled and then going
back to the point below about the
connection between the network science
and the graph like I I I don't know
because to be fair I'm new to the whole
like knowledge graph uh world but it
seems to me that there is a point of
course graining right which is if I want
to go deep deep deep there is nothing
more fundamental than let's say an
agent-based model where I'm modeling
each person's intentions and
interactions with the environment as an
individual element that's incredibly
messy. That's a network. That that's
what it is. But at the same time, maybe
if I'm smart enough, I'm going to
understand there are certain attributes
to each one of these elements in my
network that are interacting nicely with
the environment that these patterns are
picked up. Right? If I live here and I
work in finance, that means that I need
to take the Jubilee line all the way to
Canary Warf. Right? So that creates a
very stable
edge in my high level description of the
system which is finance people take the
jubilee line to Canary Warf which
actually allows me to understand maybe
not perfectly but at least it's a it's a
almost like a symmetry of the system
right it's something that's fundamental
and and there are different levels to
that right which is maybe I'm going to
end up with a huge knowledge graph that
tells me all of the professions and all
of the destinations
But maybe I'm only interested in that
one thing. So how can I actually
simplify further that graph and I think
this is where the connection lies right
between network science which is very
much down to the barebones to graph
theory which is still complex but at
least it's representing something that's
stable about the system to you know
basic data science tableabler right
which is even more course grade.
So, so, uh, I want to hear from wei on
this because, uh, you said something
about the the coarse grain concept and
I've heard U wei speak about
abstractions and how to compute, how to
communicate the essence of something and
the need for information hierarchy and
and analytics hierarchy. So, I think
there's there's some interesting points
there.
>> Yeah, that's very interesting.
Uh I have to be very honest like and I
was googling or we chatting what's no
chibing
what's the difference between network
science and the graph theory this
morning
>> oh what did it say I um it's still not
very clear to me I think it's a like you
said it's it's a two side of single coin
um I and the difference never occurred
to me that uh what Um but one thing um I
my own experience is uh
it's just like you're modeling things
the modeling things depends on what
exactly you're modeling first and with
the graph I realized this is my own
experience okay so graph is one
projection of the data like the data can
be projection as a dimensional data can
be projection into the graph
how you project into the graph. Uh you
have a choice like that's exactly how
the graph is formed and uh the same data
set can be projecting to many different
kind of graph and so u my uh personal
experience is like uh it's like the
messiness here. It's there's a lot work
into how do you figure out what exactly
you want to represent in the graph. I'm
not sure if I answered the question, but
>> I think it's a it's good insight though
is is you know understanding the
hierarchy and the coarse grace what to
course grain depends on what you're
trying to what questions you're trying
to answer and and what you're trying to
model. Um that kind of you know makes me
think that we jumped into some detail.
Um but I' I'd actually like to talk a
little bit about um the networks
themselves and what they tell us. So one
of the things I've noticed the last few
days um we have a lot of knowledge graph
professionals here that are trying to
you know abstract or or contain um
domain specific knowledge so they can
then query it so they can ask it
something but one of the magics of
networks I I believe is they tell us
things that we're not looking for. Uh,
and so I was wondering if each of you
maybe could could talk a little bit
about um either the the typical networks
you tend to work with and uh if there
are common ways that they function or
operate um that that they're actually
communicating to us if we're actually
listening. So um way you've got the mic
if you want to you want to go ahead and
start go for it.
>> Yeah. I I I there's a two side of it. Um
there's um there's a beauty side of it
and there's a utility side of it. Um so
like when we listen to music uh when we
watch a dance performance it's it's not
something we can describe especially
watch a dance performance it can be so
abstract and uh you just feel something
but you can't really describe it. uh I
found that with the especially with the
graph data visualization there's a lot
of it is in you getting you you you see
something happening you see a very
distinctive qu uh qualities like for
example we we did a study of uh uh how
people collaborate in the different
industries and once you you look at the
data there's no way you can tell
anything but once you present them as a
graph you suddenly realize there's a
very distinctive qualities in the how
people communicate in the different
industry
But then you can find the design some
matrix to capture it. But then the first
step of like this is the match of a
graph that you can actually feel just
like watch a dance like a two dancers
you feel they're very distinctive
qualities and then you can trying to
figure out the other side is like when
you go to the small like you were trying
to quantify uh some like specific uh
elements in that things I felt like it's
more traditional data science work like
uh the working at the detailed designing
formulas to to ma to measure it to
quantify it. So that's my experience.
>> I actually or um to kind of go like on
the exact like almost the other end of
the spectrum I would imagine and maybe
this is a misconception that a lot of
times you're you're looking at a network
or analyzing network and you don't know
what you're looking for like you're
you're trying to get it to speak to you.
Is that the case? And and what's if so
what's that like?
>> So I'm looking at things at two levels.
One is democra where I'm looking at
different patterns. So there could be
shifts in culture and how people shop or
how people move and what people actually
like to do and it might be economic
trends uh and you know it might be new
technologies that are being
in introduced into the environment. So
you see all of these patterns and you
can start to see some kind of
correlation definitely not causation.
going back to your talk, but you look at
it at the systemic level and the key
element for me is always okay how do I
understand the network behavior that
explains that given that that at the
network level which is the local level
it won't actually represent those
systemic uh phenomena because the whole
point of a systemic phenomena is that
you can't actually see it at the unit
level but everything is generated at the
unit level. At the end of the day, no
one works, no one operates at the
systemic level. It is for us to make
sense of a system, but everything around
us from you know who created the carpet
to who put the lights to who put the
conference together is all individual
network interactions. So it's really I
think that is you know the big challenge
of how do you start to connect that
understand the incentive structure and
then try to iterate and experiment and
and at the end of the day shift
individual incentive structures within
interactions at the network level in
order to change the systemic patterns
that we see.
Um, so, so, and I'm sure we could talk
on just that alone for for a long time,
but Allison, um, as as someone who is
hasn't been a network scientist, but now
you're you're looking at networks from a
data science standpoint. Yeah.
>> Um, are there any surprises, uh, where
you felt like the the, uh, the data set
was actually telling you something you
didn't know, you know, ahead of time?
>> Yeah. Um, so I've been a graph lover for
many, many years. And so for me like to
your point when I when I think of my
traditional data science and the way I
would always teach my students is just
keep slicing and dicing and looking at
it until you say oh that's weird and as
soon as you start saying oh that's weird
a couple of times like and getting back
to our earlier point of the magic is in
the messy I think this the same applies
when we're looking at networks and we're
looking at graphs in general is yes you
build you build the graph to answer a
question, but we have to maintain that
curiosity and that exploration in order
to let it tell us those stories and find
those things. And I think that's where
the the real art of being in graph
analytics comes to light where you can
take the soft eye and look at it in
general and see if there's something
nuanced or just spend the time to poke
around and see what's there because
there are definitely interesting things
happening and there are definitely
things that we are not necessarily aware
of and we have to let that speak. you
know, right now everybody's doing, you
know, talk to your PDFs and, you know,
knowledge graphs and like all this
stuff. Um, and you know, we have
something called the knowledge graph
builder and really it just goes through
and does entity recognition and creates
relationships based on that. And I
always tell people run it with no
guidance. Just let it imagine and just
tell you what's in the text because it's
very possible there's something there
that you don't know about. So I think to
bring the the the freedom of even when
you're building the graph to let it
build itself in some ways and to have
that curiosity and that exploration when
looking at what it's giving you. That's
where I think you're going to find those
let letting the graph talk to you,
letting the network speak to you.
>> All right, Andre. The weird. What have
you seen that's the weird in your
networks?
>> Thank you. Thank you. Yeah, I think that
like uh I'm going to try to answer two
questions in one, right? which is to
complement exactly what you just said
which is uh I think that the role of the
role of science in data science is
actually
um how do I put it right which is you're
looking at the data but the data is
often times an incomplete representation
of reality because it hides many things
that aren't necessarily that cannot be
expressable through the snapshot of data
that you have access to. Right? So
you're seeing someone commute from one
place to the other. How how do you know
what's motivating that? H but that's the
core of that's the reason why we're
here, right? Because our role as
scientists is actually to propose
hypothesis, derive the consequences of
this hypothesis, measure that against
the data and then to say this is a good
hypothesis. Yes. How do I continue to
look for evidence that my hypothesis is
false? Uh which is oh that's weird.
That's when I realized that actually
some hypothesis that I had before about
the data have been uh falsified and
actually I need to learn something else.
So it's always that process of uh
proposing something, observing something
that shatters it, learning something and
actually creating an even bigger image
uh that that's more conceptually sound
and also verified by the data um which
is goes but that's always an incomplete
process, right? Because if I I have
light that shines through the wall, if I
put a sphere in there, I know that the
shadow is going to be circular. But if I
put a cylinder rotated exactly the right
way, it's also going to be a circle. So
you need to be always aware about the
fact that there may be competing
hypothesis that explain the data. Uh
right. So so and and that's an issue
especially when you go into more uh like
specific use cases in the industry.
Right? So if you if you're a bank and
you need to measure you need to uh you
issue loans to lots of different people
you have the data which is how often do
they uh correlate like how often do the
defaults correlate together which is uh
uh very much like a a simple data
science problem. uh you can extrapolate
that into the future and think well the
correlations are low so I'm well
protected right it's very unlikely that
everyone is going to default at the same
time that's a bad hypothesis because
you're not explaining why that
correlation exists you're just assuming
that it's there but now let's say that
you go an extra step and it's like let
me build a model of the world which is
like a network these people they work in
different companies these companies they
have these properties is which you know
imagine that you're in a city where
everyone works for exactly the same
company what happens if that company
goes under everyone is going to default
on their loans so that that is a more
robust model because I can ask now the
question what would happen if something
goes all right right and that company
goes down and I have a better risk model
and that's exactly what for instance
happened in 2008 which is everyone is
using goshopolis which is just let's fit
a correlation but not thinking about the
network effects. That is actually the
true underlying model that uh would
capture these joint uh uh default
probabilities that ended up you know
putting a lot of people out of business.
So it occurs to me that um maybe it
might make sense to talk a little bit
about what does it mean to take a
network science approach to a problem or
a data set and when should people either
apply that or maybe not apply that
because not believe it or not everything
is a network science problem. Um some
things it's just statistical
correlations you're trying to do. So
yeah when um since if you would like to
go first since you have the mic. Yeah, I
think that the the
there are certain things that you I mean
there's no point in in trying to come up
with like a solid model for that, right?
Suppose that I just want to understand
where it's going to rain tomorrow. Yeah,
I mean I can just predict the weather
and that's it. My my my life doesn't
depend on it like the outcomes don't
depend on it. Uh don't depend on on the
on the idea of being able to model the
system exactly. I just want a clear
prediction. But now I have other
situations which are I want to intervene
on the system. If I want to intervene on
the system then I'm automatically
shifting the system out of distribution.
Right? I have the observed data. The
observed data is dead in the past.
>> It's only telling me about things that
have happened uh but they were generated
by the truth and the truth is the
hardest thing right because there's only
one truth. Everything else is a lie. uh
so but if I want to go beyond the data
that I've observed I actually need to
think in in more precise terms like what
was the right truth that generated that
thing or the distribution of possible
tourists that generated that thing and
what will be the impacts of my
intervention in the system how risky is
it for me if this thing happens versus
that other thing happens and I think
this is when your when your outcomes
depend on not necessarily what happened
or what may happen But like what can you
do about it and what if this this this
happens then you need to to be very
clear in your thinking about producing
like the the true underlying model of
that system.
>> Uh interesting or uh and I wonder if or
agrees because you know even basic
research is even if you're not trying to
make an intervention you're trying to
you know just understand. Um I' I'd love
to hear your thoughts on you know the
kinds of problems that you try to solve.
And for those that didn't hear uh
yesterday, just a even a little bit
about your serendipity research because
it's fascinating. Yeah.
>> Um so as I mentioned um I'm researching
the future of cities and what I'm
particularly interested in is the social
fabric. So there's so much great work,
you know, being done on mobility and all
the infrastructure and making, you know,
our cities green and and viable. Um and
another side of it is how do we keep our
social fabric viable and thriving
especially given that social friction
that has enabled this vibrancy is
actually being removed through
technology because we don't need to ask
for directions or to interact with just
those little everyday uh social
frictions that we had before. So if you
think about cities as networks by
definition and cities have evolved as a
solution to allow humans to operate in
dense networks and therefore maximize
our innovation. So think about any era
in history with huge innovation. You
know you will always find a city at its
core. So there is something there in
terms of how we organize oursel. This is
our hive. Um so if if this is about
allowing networks to thrive then under
what conditions do social networks
really thrive. So it is about the
stickiness of interconnectivity but also
accessibility. So how can you access the
networks and connect to new nodes? You
can think about it in those terms and a
lot of it is serendipitous right? the
more interactions we have, the more
connections we can potentially
probabilistically
build. Um, so I'm looking at it from
this direction. And I think that so the
problem is that there is so much data
and so many elements and so many
variables that you could look at. Uh the
difficulty and this kind of to answer
your question of when you shouldn't use
it is really when you don't really have
enough data about the different
variables and I think that there's a
natural inclination so we'll just work
with what we have but then it reduces
the phenomena that you can actually
explore so much that you kind of lose a
lot of your hypothesis. So, uh, if you
can actually test your hypothesis with
the data, then that's great. But if this
is about a negotiation of, well, I can't
really do this, so maybe I'll redefine
it in a different way, then don't go
down that route.
>> All right. Al Allison is somebody who,
you know, has to sometimes just make
something work.
>> What you're talking about, do you Yeah.
What do What do you think about what Or
just said about when not to use it?
Well, I mean, my my inclination is
there's so many people who aren't using
it when they're supposed to that the
default is I would say check and see if
there's something you can get from that
context first because I think most of
the time folks fall more often to the
other side. Obviously in this crowd
we're in a network you know um and we're
in a graph space but for everybody else
at home who may not be I would say look
to it more. Um but to your point what do
we do when we don't have the data we
need to
test a hypothesis or come to a
conclusion.
I mean for me it always goes back to the
word thoughtful which is if you have to
be really clear about is it can I
actually
stand on this statement or this outcome
that I'm saying this analysis or not and
it it really comes down to just
mathematical integrity and am I am I
forcing an answer where there isn't one
and we as analysts have to be
comfortable having the voice saying no
we can't actually test this hypothesis.
Um we don't have we don't have that
answer and to be okay with not having
that answer. And you can move the
conversation into proxy. You can move
the conversation into well let's
possibly look at it another way. But we
have to be very comfortable saying no I
can't test that.
Um, okay. So, so way I'm going to ask
you to tell me if I'm wrong or missing
something. So, what I what I'm uh what
I'm hearing from some of this
conversation is, you know, if you're if
you're thinking about applying a network
science approach to a a problem or data
set, um there are things like um
influence that you might want to see if
even if you're thinking about like
trying to find the arrow of why or or
the cause, you're talking about
influence. Um there might be groupings.
I think a lot of people are used to
working with groups and communities that
you you know how are things clustered.
Uh you might be looking at resource flow
uh something or and I have talked a lot
or or just any how anything flows uh and
uh you might also be just trying to
understand how something moves through a
system is as well and I might be I'm
probably missing a few things as well.
So, so we what do you is there anything
in there missing or what other things
types of questions um that you might
want to take a graph data science or a
network science approach to?
>> That's a really good question
and partially it's because the whole
thing is so messy
and
>> way to bring it back.
>> Yeah. Um in my
so my works become more and more
practical these days. is just solving
practical problem and the data science
is everywhere in the problem solving but
often the most difficult part is getting
the data right
>> and um and also even like I think and
you touch up on like the data collected
um
there's um so many
like fundamentally defining things is so
hard, right? We our our knowledge
depends on how we define things. And
when it come to the network, you have
abstract to node and edge, abstract to
the type and relationships.
That level abstraction already
kind of limits a lot of uh informations.
You als you already cast a lot of
shadows like a ball and versus a
cylinder. you already cast them or a lot
of shadows and then you perform a uh
network science uh analysis over it like
there's certain things like where the
top topography is really tell you a lot
of informations but then there are
certain
>> can you give us an example of that
>> uh like uh
the uh uh the flocking of the birds how
like how the birds relate to each other
they creates flocking phenomenon
fractals
uh that come out they have a very
distinctive features um a uh a
scale-free network. Uh so all those
things they have very very clear like uh
um things you can actually measure you
can you can observe and measure uh that
that system level things you can
actually measure really well. Um I
remember like 2016 I was really
interesting to see uh the left cam the
right cam in US election if if anybody
remember the trauma of those days. Um so
I monitored uh Twitter network from the
whole year and then started the network
of the left camp versus right camp with
the goal to see is there any people
change the camp? What may cause them
change the camp? To my uh disappointment
in the end my conclusion is like nobody
changed their mind
but
the the whole process uh requires a lot
of um like clustering uh community
detection can work but in the end I
realized that that like when they come
to the specific information like thing I
want to extract I almost have to rewrite
algorithm to be able to describe that um
and even then because we only have a
partial data that um
that really to to con uh
at the network and the on the on the
whole system level I felt like network
science can give a lot of information
but on the detailed individual level uh
that the picture might be different
that's my feeling
>> I that's interesting you think about
like system level versus, you know,
individual. And I I I do sometimes think
about when I think about um you know,
people that are are are really steeped
in the knowledge graph um industry, a
lot of times we're we're trying to
answer a question. We know what we want
to ask. And I think there's this um
serend serendipitous discovery uh you
know, that can happen uh when you're
looking at a larger system level. Um,
but it's you don't know what you're
looking at ahead of time and it's at a
kind of a a larger mass level. Um, I'm
wondering actually if there are
questions here in the audience and we we
do have one and I'm very close. So, oh,
>> can you take
>> Yeah, I got it. I got it.
>> Uh, so what I'm interested in is uh
trying to connect what you're talking
about with with ontology and some of the
other stuff that that is going on. And I
am interested in that in a in a very
fundamental way which is that um as
you're talking about if
in order to act in the world we've got
to model things. We've got we've got to
generate a representation that is a
simplification
um and we as humans do that and that
those representations are are in our
neural network. Likewise in an LLM the
it will be developing something like a a
symbolic representation in the network.
And I'm wondering if any of you have any
thoughts on the feasibility of using
network and analytics tools or graph
data science tools to start getting an
understanding of what are the emergent
uh concepts or symbols in some of these
networks in order to then connect them
with the the explicit formal semantics
of the systems.
So let let me play back to you just to
just just to make sure that uh I'm
answering the right question which is
for instance you can view uh a language
model itself as a network right in which
there is some level of complexity that
is happening within the way that
information is flowing through that
network because effectively it's just a
connection of nodes that are connected
by certain weights with some
nonlinearity that are transforming these
ad nauseion until it spits something
out. Yeah. So you may want to look into
a paper which is called Hopfield is all
you need. Uh Hopfield who actually won
the Nobel Prize uh for doing something
which is uh associative uh memories. I
hope that I'm not butchering the the
whole research program. But the idea is
the following, right? His idea is is is
like this. So you're you're in
statistical physics so you know this
much better than everyone here which is
I have a spin system basically particles
in a latis and they communicate with
each other and there is some repulsion
or some attraction between them in such
a way that if I flip the spin of one
particle up the others one around it
will react to it and we want to go up or
down right so now you can think about it
yeah okay that's a boring system what
can I do with it now it turns out that
if you make the interaction s
complicated enough. You can actually
define the connections in such a way
like those coupling
strengths between the different
particles like let's say particle 0 is
coupled to particle 00 is coupled to 01
which is coupled to one one and so on
with a different coupling per particle.
There's a big matrix. So you can define
these couplings in such a way that the
couplings themselves the system stores
memories right in such a way that if I
encode an image in there it will
remember that image in such a way that
now I reinitialize the spins all the way
and I kick one spin in one direction I
let the system evolve and it will evolve
to exactly uh give me back my image in
which which was stored. Uh so this was
his work back in the in the old days.
Turns out that transformers look like a
completely different beast, right? Is
essentially just a bunch of matrix
matrix multiplications. But there's a
lot of research in actually trying to
represent the transformer like
essentially that specific calculation
into the output of that hopfield
network, right?
uh to essentially link the two things
which turns out mathematically you can
show that there is exact uh
correspondence between them and that
leads to something which is energybased
models in which language models aren't
necessarily doing that that
transformation just because they are
doing it because they are minimizing an
energy functional where the underlying
let's say system whose energy is being
minimized is just a spin network. So
there is an exact correspondence between
like what language models are doing and
and these sorts of very complicated uh
networks.
>> Way to go deep Andre. Wow. Yeah. So I
take some note. I'm wondering um as
people weey and Allison that that deal
with um uh a people already using graphs
if there are ways that um have helped
them connect network science ideas,
principles, practices to maybe current
graphs that that they may have.
>> You're up first.
Um
I I have uh collaborated with uh some um
researchers on how to optimize the uh um
efficiency in the collaboration in the
uh in in the industry. Um now of course
the the the end result is not very clear
and there's some ideas and the there's
some some also practical things is more
like um um
in large network um in application of
taking down some like uh nefarious
network activities
and
trying to figure out. So that those are
really clear example of you need to look
at the both large scale systematic
characteristic but also also it's very
important to be able to get down to the
local level. uh the local level is often
things gets more complicated gets like
uh fuzzy like uh uh then the information
from network is often not sufficient
that it give you indication but then you
have augment with other some real world
informations that's just my experience
>> I think one of the things that um you
and if let me know if this is not the
question you were asking one of the
things that's possible is, you know,
when sometimes when folks go in and
they're using graph for the first time,
they have an idea of what the ontology
should be and it's not always
necessarily what's in the data itself.
And so I think sometimes there are
opportunities to let the ontology speak
to you. The way that I see it most often
is from unstructured data. And it's like
I was saying before to really let what's
naturally in that unstructured data sort
of come to the four and tell you what
its ontology is and then put that back
to you know does that actually make
sense but really keeping it open to
understanding
are there other aspects of a hierarchy
or other aspects of a representation
that we haven't considered that is
already existing in the data itself.
So, I don't know if that answers your
question, but that's where I I think I
think oftent times there's much more of
a need for an ontological layer in order
for the graph to and that network to
really speak to answering the questions
and really have being a good
representation and abstraction of what
that data actually is. Um, and so I just
think we need more of it in a lot of
those commercial settings.
>> So, so Orura, I don't know if you have
some ideas um either with somebody
already using a graph or um maybe what
tools, you know, you find the most
helpful um for your analysis.
>> So, I actually don't have solutions. Um,
and I'm I'm really interested in in
those types of challenges. So, so my
talk yesterday was mainly about how can
you analyze a vibe? Um, can you actually
capture a vibe? And that that relates to
what you mentioned about humans doing
things in a very natural way and can we
replicate it? Because when we go into a
room or any other space, we we
intuitively immediately sense the vibe
and we can describe it for ourselves.
It's an it's an you know it's an emotion
that we intuitively sense and yet
what would it mean in terms of you know
understanding its ontological mapping
and understanding it it's its um process
of emergence I'm not even going there
but how do you actually capture that
within the system and I think that if we
had an almost vibe machine where we
could analyze a vibe and then intervene
within the space to to make the vibe
better then it would be a very useful
instrument and I think that this is more
of a puzzle for me right now in terms of
what you could use. So
any suggestions?
Well, it just brings me back to what
Andre was saying before about the you
know the mapping of the spinning of
everything. It it seems to me like it's
a very similar type of situation. So if
you want to get to a particular picture,
you want to get to a particular vibe,
you have just have to figure out which
levers to move, right? And we see that
just as humans, right? I mean, you walk
into a room and something is weird is a
way and you say, "How can I bring X to
this and how can I move that?" So it
just sounds very much like what you were
saying earlier.
>> Exactly.
Yeah, it's true because I I think that
what you're saying as well is really
interesting because there are concepts
which are really hard to uh put a box on
it, right? They live in they live in an
abstract layer which uh it's almost like
I know it when I see it. Yeah.
>> Uh but but the question is maybe is
there a way to look at a 100 different
rooms, capture data on everything and
then cluster the rooms and then point
out, oh this room has a good vibe, this
room has a bad vibe.
>> Sure. Exactly. Let's do that. That that
seems amazing. Right. Because I do think
that there like as human beings even
when it comes to communication, right?
because we're so focused on language now
but in reality most of our communication
doesn't even happen at the at the level
of language and uh and it seems a lot
it's it's not only multimodal in the
sense that I'm seeing things but it's
also multiensorial
sensorial is not the right word but like
there is a system in my brain that I can
look at someone and I can kind of feel
some type of uh you know either like a a
good feeling right because a person
seems receptive or not or the person
seems aggressive, but are these tiny
little things and we don't have a good
taxonomy or ontology or whatever to
classify this. And this is a trouble
going back to what you were saying
yesterday uh way, which is when you put
a a label on it, you're automatically
reducing the complexity of its
description, which is like how do I put
a label on a vibe? Even though it's
useful from the point of view of like
okay I want to do science I need a label
but
yeah what else how how can I you know
make it softer right such that I can put
things on a on a bigger spectrum rather
than just true or false
>> yeah I think the soft edges thing is
really
>> No I'm just saying just to ask you more
questions I mean I think creating softer
boundaries is is one of the key
challenges is almost like membranes that
things can still move through and it's
not a boundary.
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly. So I just like I I like to say
this but people may laugh at me but
there's um there's a uh about 2500 years
ago there's a two philosophical thought
happening in one Greek way in China. Uh
the uh the the Greek philosophy is more
focused on categorization and naming.
identify that everything has essence.
the naming is a pro approximation is
necessary which leads into the uh the
vibrant science technology developed in
the in in the Europe in the in the west
world the Chinese way have a intuition
that's really interesting says like uh
do so translate English is if you name
something you get it wrong
>> so
>> and uh it's really interesting
>> you do know where you are right
>> what
>> no I said you do know what conference
you're at no I'm Right.
>> Yeah. The next thing it says like uh
everything nothing has the permanent
like essence. The essence only be like
emerges when it's in contact of other
things. So hence like I'm looking at the
like you talk about the uh uh using LM
to decipher language. Jul talk about let
let the ontology
>> come out to you emerge from it instead
of uh instead of uh like trying to
predefine it and then try to fit into
into the into the box. I think that's
like you you probably grew up in China I
guess.
So, so that's that's that that way of
thinking for me it's it's really it's
interesting because on one hand if you
don't name things uh everything is just
like you can't develop things if you
name things too strictly too early uh
you also have a problem you you fit
everything into a small silos and it's
the deviate from the true essence
uh so I think that the uh the balance is
the network
>> uh the uh when you have when you can
describe things in network you actually
have a lot of tolerance of uh of feeding
things in the silo or a lot of un like a
lot of uh uncertainty to emerge like you
just said in the in in this approach. So
I think the one of the thing that it's
more intuition to me but have not yet be
able to like uh uh really like bring
that out the verbalize is is how a
network can be used to to to represent
the the uh the system the environment in
a way that impossible to represent
before with the ontology.
>> Yeah.
>> Can I add to that?
>> Yeah, go ahead. And we we have about
five minutes left I think. How we
>> about 15?
>> Oh we have 15. Never go we can go for
it. We have 15 minutes.
>> So just a question maybe it is about
inserting flows. So focusing on the
flows rather than on the nodes and on
the structure because then you could
capture those elements in their
temporary state. Uh so I don't know if
any of you are doing any flows analysis
within the structure.
>> There is a there's a lot of people
thinking about flows right now and now
sorry I'm going to nerd out again.
Wake me up uh in a second. No for
instance uh because we we we're often
thinking about these things in a very
much like uh
as in this is a snapshot of my system,
right? But in reality you like you can
sort of represent the data as these are
my states and there is a transition
between different states. Uh and that
that itself is going to be a network as
well right because you can have a
network of different states. uh the
boring cases if you think about uh I
don't know like or actually not not
boring the really interesting is we were
in a talk about football yesterday and
we're like okay this is the the network
which is there is a transition between
different states which is the ball is
here now the ball is there because of
this action
>> and the players are flowing around which
is uh I think it's it's an interesting
area uh for AI as well uh because you
you have people like even Joshua Benju
is working on something called
generative flow networks. Uh there the
whole um
uh there's a whole reinforcement
learning community which is kind of
working on top of a network exactly of
states and transitions between states.
Uh so so the the question is how to sort
of putting this world this this world of
reinforcement learning this world of
state modeling and this world of kind of
knowledge graph which if you think about
text if you think about the description
of a system it's not so it's a bit more
fluid right uh so so yeah so it's not a
right answer to you but it's a statement
that there are people working on kind of
flow within networks but in slightly
different uh uh uh slightly different
contexts.
>> All right, since we do have a few more
minutes, are there more questions? Uh
Brashant, let me I got them all the
questions.
>> Uh yeah, so I also have a physics
background and I came into computer
science. So uh one frustration I have
with uh graph data science network
science whatever the broad fuzzy bubble
of that whole field is unlike physics
where it's first principles driven you
have governing equations you have an
underlying theory and there are some
foundation ways of thinking that allow
you to construct the problem and define
what you're the what questions you're
asking and you have models that help you
answer those questions. So it's a very
structured way in my opinion of thinking
about things. But my frustration when I
look at the way graph data science is
done and all the material I've seen
online, the blogs, the videos, I've
pretty much done them all. And every
single time I have this question when
people are talking about how to do graph
data science, it seems very handwavy to
me. It feels like an art more than a
science. It feels like part of it is
because of the reason you brought up Amy
that is there is graph theory, there is
graph technology and there is network
science. I guess some statistical
methods along the way. So they're all
kind of different fields converging into
this one area. And in my case when I
work with a data set I have moved that
data from one form into a graph. So I
have already imposed a sort of structure
on that data. I have in many cases that
data makes conceptual sense. The way the
things are connected makes conceptual
sense. So what I'm my my bigger question
here is when you go through that process
when you have the data set is is it
always the case that you you can apply
these network science methods on it.
Does every data set have a network
science angle through which you can view
it and answer questions about it. Some
some of them you can just answer via
queries or aggregations uh you know
those kinds of highle questions. But
then can do you know that you're missing
out something where a network science
approach could have helped you answer
something new about that data and unlike
physics I don't have a framework of
thinking I can't do it that way so many
times I have data sets where I'm staring
at it I can see something intuitively
and my aggregations tell me that okay
the numbers make sense but then I have
no clue how to proceed like I I can
throw a dart and pick any of these
centrality algorithms or whatever other
algorithms there are But am I asking the
right question? Am I missing questions
that I could have asked that could have
helped me understand that data better?
And what more insights can I get by
thinking about that data in a more
fundamental way using a more structural
way of thinking about it?
>> As the as a graph data scientist, I feel
an obligation to be the first person to
answer your question. Um, so there were
many many things you discussed. The
first was the handwavy part. So, we'll
we'll get to that. But I think I think
your last question is probably the most
the one that needs to be addressed
first, which is how do we Oh, sorry. Oh,
thank you. Um, how do we know when we're
looking at a network or a graph that I'm
asking the right questions? And I'll be
honest, I don't think there's an answer
to that, right? It's it's like when
you're looking at any phenomenon, how do
you know that you've explored it fully?
How do you know what you haven't looked
at? I think, you know, there are there
are pieces you can go through, you know,
classic exploratory data analysis. I
want to look at this and that. And you
you can certainly have a framework of
steps you want to go through when you're
looking at the graph, but I don't I
don't know that
it it's hard to know that you've hit
everything, right? So some of some of
that is I does that answer your
question? It's not helpful though, is
it? Right. It it feels very handwavy,
right? Um yeah. So but I don't know. But
I think that's true. I think we can, you
know, as scientists and people who
explore, we can look at something an
infinite number of ways. And how do you
know that you've looked at it enough
ways? I don't know, maybe life in
physics is different, but I feel like,
you know, especially when you're looking
at a complex system, like you could look
at a a city forever, right? Like there
there's an infinite number of things you
could look at. Um, going back to sort of
from a practical perspective, what do we
want to do when we put it together? I
think even just what you were saying,
you've transformed that data into the
graph itself. And that's the one thing
that I also wanted to talk about is
the the human element of what is a what
is an entity, what is a relationship,
what goes in as a property, what don't
you include, what do you include, how do
you I mean there is a lot of art in it
and there is a lot of possibility and
there's an infinite number of ways that
you can take tabular data and put it
into a network and there's a there's a
certain amount of responsibility of your
own perspective that you have to own
when you then look at it. So I don't
know that you can say I've looked at it
enough ever. Um but I don't know how
that differs from physics.
>> So that's actually really good points
and really good talk. I have two
thoughts and I felt like feel like the
today's tooling uh is missing. uh salt
number one um I use analogy like in uh
in physics since we have phys we have
people in physics background like when
you describe a wave right you can
there's two way describe it one is in
the physical space like something
oscillating
the other things in the frequency space
like oh I have a peak here I have the
frequency distribution and when I look
at the data and uh I think the data has
two representations you have a
dimensional representation a table
things like and you have a graph
representation the edges things. Now how
do you like look at the data from like
reconcile those two different
representations just like you you
sometime you look at the wave you you're
measuring in physical space sometime you
measure the frequency you can filter on
the frequency it's very convenient and
in in the graph data data science I
think it's connect to the the bigger
data science world through those two
projections but how do we go from in
between that's not been defined today
and then and in in the in the practical
solution I I encounter that all the time
there like I constantly need to look at
the data from a graph perspective and
also from just a data like traditional
data perspective
uh that being said the other thing is I
say the graph like today when we talk
about graph is we we often think about
as a concrete graph like we have a
person connection I think LM is like
vector embeddings is really good way of
a uh of of a kind pushing the boundary a
little bit. Now the graph is what we see
the graph I can I see that as as a
manifest of graph but be beyond the
manifest graph you have you have latent
graph like if you take a vector
embedding of of entities look at the
vector similarities that depends on if
you can project vector similarity in the
different domain different dimension you
can actually construct many different
kind of graph from the same data set so
so you have a latent graph that hidden
in the similarity like vector embedding
But you also you can have a manifest
graph. Now that's just really like in
physics problem depends on how you
project into into which dimension you
look at it. You may have a very
different thing. So in the practical
application I I felt like that kind of
thing come up all the time but we don't
really have a good framework to to even
think about that.
>> Uh I don't know or if you want to add
anything or or can you ever look at a
city enough ways? Um so that's the thing
it goes back to you know the map is not
the territory element I think that you
always start with what are you trying to
do so for me it is the puzzle and there
is no model for the system you cannot
represent the system in any model you
are modeling in order to help you make
sense of the system and there are two
different things so the boundaries that
you place on the system really depends
on what is the puzzle and who you are
within the system because in terms of
what you can do, your capacities, your
mandate, your position within the system
that actually influence how you will
look at the system that you're trying to
change. So I think it's more of the
strategy behind it rather than the
formation.
>> I don't know if that helps. I
>> I think that's great advice. Um I want
to wrap up with some final thoughts and
and maybe
>> Oh, and one more question. But hey, we
we've got time.
>> Yeah, we got time. Do you have a
question?
>> Do one or two?
>> Yeah, let's do it.
>> And and thanks for really interesting
discussion. So, uh working from the
initial uh discussion from the other
session, we we there was a term that
sort of resonated with me, the idea of a
noledge graph because I think it's such
a beautiful expression for research
proposal. So if we follow your your your
causality graph and it works and we fast
forward a thousand years, wouldn't that
be a a a danger to society that we could
become uh dogmatic in sort of getting
rid of information noise, data noise in
that process? So do we need an
anti-thesis to that? a sort
offormational antimatter where a
knowledge graph could contain elements
that could be both uh true and false.
Could that be a sort of quantum causal
graph?
>> That's an interesting problem.
>> Look, I I think that there there are two
okay there are three underlying problems
there which is like the data may lie to
you.
uh or actually I I wasn't part of the
other discussion but let me try to
paraphrase what you're trying to say
which is that you have an anti knowledge
graph which is these things are false
and I know that they're false right and
I'm trying to represent that yeah I I
think that this is beautiful right and
like I I I won't try to answer your
question specifically because I I see
this as
um how do I put it there are things that
are inevitable right in the
And I think that the move from like a
tablo representation of the world to a
graph representation is something that I
kind of see it as inevitable because
it's a better way to represent the
systems and just it what's going to come
next I don't know maybe we're going to
move from graph to like tensor graphs
right where instead of an adjacency
matrix you have an adjacency tensor or
maybe there will come someone who is
really smart and is going to come up
with let's say the quantum uh knowledge
graph right because now we have quantum
computers as well. Or maybe there is a
need to to to represent anti-
relationships, right? Which is these
things are false no matter what. And
it's another type of domain expertise
that we should input. All of these
things, they sort of evolve in a in a
like in a need to solve a problem type
of way, right? someone is facing an
issue, they figure out that there is a
data structure that helps understand
that issue better and it helps as well
produce the right modeling techniques on
top of that. So why not? But but but I
do think that this is just the
beginning, right? So if you think about
it, this is a fairly small conference,
but it's very packed with uh uh
>> really smart people.
>> Exactly.
And Yeah. And it's not just smart,
right? Because if you go to Europe,
you're also going to find a lot of smart
people, but it's but you kind of feel
like you're in a point of saturation
where there's a lot of uh tiny little
things that get thrown into a wall uh in
order to improve to do incremental
improvements which are very small.
Whereas here I think that the scope of
uh innovation that is happening in this
space is way more disproportionate
to the amount of effort that it takes
for instance your question is a very
like reasonable question like it's a
very big problem there are people like
with massive problems like there are
people who are talking about saving
lives and the amount of thought that is
needed like going back to your question
as well I don't have the right toolkits
that's great that that's that's
That's an amazing statement for for
someone to have because that means that
we we we we have more problems than
solutions and I think it's basically our
job to sort of come up with the right
ways of of uh dealing with it. Yeah.
Sorry that was a known answer to your
question but hopefully it was
>> there's some interesting research by the
way um going on right now on um
creativity in AI um where you're you're
it's not a hallucination. you're
purposely um creating connections. Uh
and there's a there's some colleagues
actually a colleague of of of wean eyes
um that has been talking about uh using
some approaches where you um you might
even call it dreaming um where you're uh
allowing a system to basically do link
prediction making links depending on
weights uh and maybe arbitrarily at
times dropping them depending on you
know circumstances. And I think what
that kind of shows is a well we it is
early days but this understanding that
messiness is important and if we take
all the messiness out of the system if
we um try to assume that we've named
everything correctly uh that uh that we
we could understand the model of the
system and say okay that's it we're
going to go forward this is our our AI
system that knows everything we know we
are wrong uh and so building some
messiness iness into the systems I I
think is absolutely important. I love
the question. Um there are people
talking about it. I haven't seen a paper
on it yet. I haven't seen any system on
it yet. It's just conversations which
maybe goes back to your point about the
um the conversation the innovation level
to you know to to the problems. Um uh
the other thing I do so I I don't know.
So so thank you for that. Um fascinating
area. Uh, the other thing I've noticed,
I don't know if everyone else has
noticed this. It's there's this
interesting tension and I've I saw it a
little bit in Tony Seal's um talk and
I'm I'm seeing it a lot here between
let's name things, let's not name
things. Let's look at the gran we've
practically have to look at the granular
level, but oh god, don't look at the
granular levers. We we we will miss out
on the big emergent, you know, level.
Um, let's model, let's not model. um
this kind of tension of of back and
forth between uh capturing the messiness
and uh not being overly uh overbearing
about it. And I and I I I find that a
fascinating area and one where I'm
hoping
as opposed to saying we need a
centralized system that does X or a
decentralized system that does Y that if
you think about networks themselves and
I often think about fungus because who
doesn't love fungus um from a from a
network scientist standpoint and
resource flow and expansion is there's
this natural back and forth between edge
messing iness and taking a wrong path
and centralization of resources but not
overly centralization communication but
not too much communication. So I think
nature has somehow figured this out and
uh the structure uh and the shape that a
lot of things happen in nature is for a
function. And I I often wonder if
we might be moving at some point into AI
systems that can be more network like or
more nature-like where they can
understand the balance of these two
tensions because you know we've been
saying you know this last couple hours
or however long it's been you know the
kind of this tension between it's it's
you know you need this but don't do too
much of that sort of a thing. So, I
don't know if if you guys are are
sensing that as well, but I I'm seeing a
lot of that. Um, I don't know what to do
with that, though. Uh, any final
thoughts as we we start to uh
incentives, right? Because nature gives
us very good incentives, which is to
survive, and then you end up with these
things like self-organized criticality
or whatever you may want to call it,
which to be fair right now, you go to
every every layer in a hierarchy. Then
you observe phenomena which are emerging
phenomena, which are sort of
self-organizing. City is the perfect
example of that, right? Which to some
extent no one no one told the city to be
a city. The city just came to be because
it's beneficial for everyone to be in
the city. You have things such as
competition but you then you have
cooperation, right? You have a street
with only carpet sellers like they're
competing but at the same time they know
that they need to cooperate. So these
things are fascinating to me and I think
they're sort of unexplored in the AI
space which is how do how do we uh how
do we put the right incentives for
different agentic systems to cooperate
and maybe compete in such a way that the
uh that the emergent properties are
bigger than the sum.
>> Yeah just to continue on that because
there is a logic to the emergent
property that's the key. So cities have
have evolved as a solution to a problem
and the problem was how do human
networks uh thrive. So in that sense
this is why my talk yesterday was about
serendipity. There is the random
element. So the density maximizes
actually the random collisions between
people and that is the engine that makes
the magic happen. Um, and I'm wondering
where you on the one hand model and in
just insert randomity into models and
see what happens, but also for me uh
going back to what I said, I'm looking
also at individual behavior but overall
trends. I'm always looking for
contradictions
and I'm wondering if some of the models
uh should rather than highlight states
or highlight you know give us answers
just highlight the contradictions
because it is within within those
systemic tensions that I find the most
interesting kind of solutions lie.
Uh I am going to make the case for more
randomness and more noise in our models.
Um I think you know especially in our AI
systems when we I think I'll be honest I
think the data science community over
the last 10 to 15 years has been so
committed to getting the right answer
that we've actually done a lot of
damage. um you know the echo chamber the
idea that we just keep giving people
more and more of what we want then we
lose the tail we lose the serendipity we
lose the the exposure to other and I
think it is extremely critical in this
the AI space that we're in and the fact
that you know everyone is using AI now
and there's this lack of understanding
of what it does and I Think the more
that we can encourage our own industry
to
veer away a little bit from the signal,
we can't stay just on the signal. We
have to keep that randomness. We have to
keep those messy edges of the system in
order for the system to thrive. And so
we have to find a way to really be
committed to that for the overall
impact, the societal impact of what
we're doing.
Well, um I just feel like we're living
in a very very interesting time. Um and
thinking about the graph, I felt that
the um graph is such important
technology. Uh but it's um constantly
being kind of considered as a niche
market, niche technology and it's
because there's not enough data for
graph. There's a specific problem that
fits graph. But now we have a large
language model which can turn all the
informations that we otherwise never
consider as the data suddenly become
data and guess what and uh that data
needs graph to to hold it. So suddenly
we have uh unlimit among the data coming
towards us as a as a graph like
specialist.
uh you know I I just felt like um it's
be interesting time to start thinking
about how the network science can be
applied to this new wave of graph data
that coming towards us.
>> All right. I feel so honored just to be
in this conversation. I this is probably
um it has to rank as maybe the best
conversation uh in the last few days.
Really made me think about some things
differently. I I keep thinking there's
oh there's some keynote talks in here on
Jesse subic randomness. Thank god it's
wrong you know whatever you know let's
drop the signal. Yay noise. Um there's
all sorts of there's all sorts of fun
things we could do. Um if there are no
other questions I think we probably need
to wrap it up. I'm
>> we should Okay. All right. So um thank
you for you know thoughts, energy,
creativity. Thank you for the weird uh
the random, the phil uh philosophy, the
physics uh yeah and the ontology in the
middle of it all. So, thank you
everybody.
>> Thank you very much.